so there's this one nutrient that has
been researched over 2 000 times and 30
of those research projects involved
human clinical trials okay so anytime
something has been researched that much
it gets my attention so I want to talk
about it sulforaphane it's not a vitamin
it's not a mineral it's not a trace
mineral it's not a fatty acid it's a
phytonutrient so the question is why are
researchers looking at this molecule I
mean it's a tremendous amount of time
and money to invest in this one nutrient
so before I get into what it does let's
first talk about where you can get it
from okay well you can get them from
many different plants but the one that
has the most is the broccoli sprout now
if we compare a broccoli sprout or even
a broccoli micro grain which I'm going
to explain in a minute into an adult
broccoli vegetable
you have a factor of 10 to 100 times
more sulforaphane in that baby plant
then the adult vegetable that's
significant not a hundred percent more
I'm talking like 10 to 100 times more of
this very specific sulforaphane nutrient
so we have this cycle from a seed to
this adult plant so it goes to a sprout
phase which is between two and five days
and then it goes to the next phase which
is the micro green right microgreens you
probably seed them in the grocery store
or at the farmer's market but it takes
10 to 14 days to make a microgreen then
you have baby greens like the baby green
lettuce leaf which is between 15 to 40
days and then the adult vegetable takes
between 40 to 150 days so if we break
down this whole cycle of this plant
the majority of nutrients especially the
phytonutrients they kind of Spike
between the seventh and the 14th day and
it's interesting because the average
person consumes only like one and a half
cups of vegetables and basically almost
zero amount of microgreens or Sprouts
but they do consume a lot of grains
right and so what's so different about
the grain or the seed which is the same
thing and the Sprout or the micro green
is that the micro Green in the Sprout
have much less
anti-nutrients okay than the seed does
and as the adult vegetable does so
across the board these micro greens are
not only so super concentrated with not
just vitamins and minerals but
phytonutrients the antioxidants the
things that can actually help you
prevent cancer but they also have the
least amount of anti-nutrients that
irritates the gut that creates problems
for people but way more people consume
the grains and they're getting a lot of
anti-nutrients they're getting a lot of
phytic acid which blocks minerals like
zinc calcium iron things like that and
they have no problem meeting the grains
but they just don't eat enough micro
greens or vegetables in general now if
you think about this just the
concentration of nutrients you don't
need nearly the quantities of
microgreens or Sprouts than you do the
adult vegetable to get a good amount of
nutrition so you can actually have less
of that and for many people that's a
good thing because they have a hard time
consuming seven to ten cups of
vegetables so if you're just doing a
fraction of these microgreens you can
get a serious amount of these
phytonutrients and the benefits of the
phytonutrients
big Pharma is spending a lot of money
studying these sprouts and these
phytonutrients in sprouts and and
microgreens because they're loaded with
all sorts of chemicals that give certain
effects you know unfortunately the model
of medicine is like you have this one
Magic Bullet For This One symptom but
wouldn't it be better to have a whole
complex food that can have a huge wide
range of effects to your body so let's
go through these effects that
microgreens and Sprouts can give you and
phytonutrients in general and
specifically the sulfurophane one the
first thing is you get the prevention of
chronic disease anything chronic
involving inflammation can be helped
sulforaphane induces this compound
called
Nrf2 which gives a potent
anti-inflammatory effect it's not that
there's something in the sulforaphane
that's giving you something that's
similar to that Gene it's turning on
something that's already in your body
that's then going to get rid of
inflammation it's pretty wild if there's
anything chronic and degenerative that's
where you can apply this so we're
talking about arthritis Alzheimer's any
chronic inflammatory disorder now the
other thing that they really study it
for is its effect on cancer it's very
anti-cancer in fact Hopkins try to get
the patents but they got sued and they
never got the patents so they dropped it
like a hot potato but if they're trying
to get the patents and spend all the
money and they already did the research
then it's legitimate sulforaphane has
the ability to inhibit
carcinogens like Benzene for example
it's a chemical sulforaphane is a very
powerful
anti-microbial if you have for example
some virus or bacterial infection or Ace
pylori
sulforaphane can help sulforaphane has
blood sugar effects so it's good for
diabetes sulforaphane targets the inner
layer of the blood vessels okay it's
called the endothelial layer so it can
be very beneficial in preventing heart
disease sulforaphane has been studied in
autism which usually involves a lot of
oxidation and free radical damage and so
we have sulforaphane coming in there as
an antioxidant and cleaning all that up
sulforaphane has effects on Aging it can
help slow down this aging process to a
certain degree sulforaphane is also good
for your brain in brain repair in
protecting the brain against oxidation
so if someone has Parkinson's or
Alzheimer's they should be exposed to
these phytonutrients on a regular basis
you can do broccoli Sprouts or broccoli
microgreens you can also do the radish
microgreens or the Sprouts or the
Cabbage microgreens or the Sprouts or
the kale micro greens or the Sprouts
those are really good ones pretty much
all the Chris Cyprus Sprouts or
microgreens have a really good amount of
suffrophane but broccoli Sprouts or
broccoli micro greens have the most now
every so often you hear you have this
outbreak of E coli or salmonella and
that usually has to do with the
hydroponic growing of these
plants and the real problem with
hydroponic is you don't necessarily have
the full microbiome okay like you have
in the soil and that is the immune
system that protects against these
pathogens so if possible grow your micro
greens grow your Sprouts in actual soil
that would be a lot better it takes more
work it's Messier but if you can find a
farm that can grow some in soil
that would be the ideal situation
especially to suppress the pathogens now
on top of the benefits of the
phytonutrients okay and also getting rid
of a lot of these anti-nutrients there's
also nutrition too so let me just kind
of go through that in 100 gram amount of
microgreens you have only 4.4 grams of
carbs it's pretty low you have 2.2 grams
of fiber so the net carbs is really only
2.2 grams okay so it's virtually
non-existent then we have 2.2 grams of
protein now I wouldn't rely on your
protein from getting Sprouts but there's
some protein in there then we have 11
milligrams of sodium that's pretty darn
low
298 milligrams of potassium okay that's
that's a good amount especially since
our bodies need a lot like 4 700
milligrams of potassium every day
there's 66 milligrams of magnesium
there's 88 milligrams of calcium there's
0.7 milligrams of zinc and there's a 66
micrograms of folate but overall there's
more vitamins and minerals and
especially phytonutrients in these
Sprouts or micro greens so since you're
on this topic a really good next video
for you to watch would be the one on
sulfur effect it's going to give you
some additional data that I think is
going to be very helpful and I put that
video up right here check it out